The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right,
today's the last official day
of lecture.
We'll finish up Joshua
and Kenneth [? Reids ?],
and then we'll jump right
into post production.
Whenever you're ready.
Laptops down.
JOSHUA: The science of search.
Have you ever found it difficult
to find a particular item
in your house?
Let's say you have
lost a pair of gloves.
And you spend an entire
afternoon looking for it,
but you just can't find it.
You have encountered
the same problem
that companies like
Google or Yahoo
try to solve every single
day, the problem of search.
Just like a house, which stores
about 1,000 different items,
Google stores 45 billion
different index pages
of information.
If each page of information
was a sheet of paper
and we stack them
high altogether,
we would create
a tower 610 times
taller than Mount Everest.
How can a search
engine like Google
find your results
so quickly, when
we find it so difficult
to find a pair of gloves?
Well, it turns out, that
searching on the internet
is kind of like looking for
a person in a hotel room.
Let's suppose we're looking
for a guest called James.
To find James, the
simplest way would
be to run to every room nearest
to you until you find him.
But that would take very long.
There's a better way
known as binary search.
Let's say the people were
arranged in alphabetical order
in increasing numbers
of the hotel rooms.
We could run to the
room in the middle
and check if the name
of the person is James.
If the person's name starts
with the letter before J,
we head to the right.
If not, we would go to the left.
We then head off to the middle
room of the newly sectioned
area, and we rinse and repeat.
Eventually we'll find James,
just like the first method.
But we found him much faster
than using the first method.
How much faster would that be?
Well that depends on the
people staying in the hotel--
the number of people
staying in the hotel.
Let's say it takes ten seconds
to knock on each hotel door,
and that's 500 people.
It will take about 80
minutes for the first method,
and one and a half
minutes for binary search.
But if there were 1,000
people in the hotel room,
it would take 160 minutes
for the first method,
but only 1.6 minutes
for binary search.
Now that's a whole
lot of difference.
A name like James is just a
word, but companies like Google
taking searches for long
combination of words,
making it a little
bit more complicated.
Just like identifying the word
James from its first letter,
Google identifies
unique characteristics
of search phrases using
over 200 different factors.
Also, notice how the
better method depends on
prearrange the people
in alphabetical order?
Company scientists are
always actively looking
for better methods to sort,
manage, and eventually retrieve
the data.
In the same way, simply
by placing your home items
in location where they
have a natural relationship
to make it easier
for us to find them.
For example, the TV
remote goes near the TV.
The shoes goes
near the shoe rack.
The coats go near the
cupboard, and the winter gloves
goes in the winter jacket.
Ah-ha, so that's
where my gloves are.
And that's the story of search.
PROFESSOR: You're clocking in
around three to four minutes,
which is a really
good place to be.
All right, Joshua's script
is up on annotation studio.
Let me turn this on.
AUDIENCE: Turn to
this [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh, sorry.
Joshua, this script has come
along a really, really far way.
This is really tight, very good.
I think the flow of
it is very natural.
I also thought your
delivery was very natural.
I don't know if
you've been practicing
or maybe you've just felt a
little more at ease today,
but I think the way you
pause at certain words,
and just sort of the natural
feel of it is-- it's nice.
It sounds like you're
really just talking to us.
JOSHUA: I think I
learned a lot of Andrea.
PROFESSOR: From Andrea - yeah.
JOSHUA: [INAUDIBLE] yesterday.
PROFESSOR: When she
said-- what was it
that you said during class?
Remember--
JOSHUA: It was
basically just observing
how she presented that I
learned how [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh, you were sort of
copying her style a little bit.
Let's see, here we go.
I think something
that works really well
for this script is that
you build complexity.
Which is a topic that
we sort of talked
about earlier in
the class, but I
think is hard to really
understand unless you
see a specific example of it.
But he starts off with
a very simple example
of losing your gloves,
and then he clearly
relates it to how
Google searches
for something that is
far greater in number
and complexity.
But he connects it very clearly
to the glove analogy, which
is why I think it works.
I think this explanation
of binary search
is very clear, because
you're relating it
to the context of
the hotel analogy.
I know in earlier
iterations of your script,
you were just
describing binary search
as a concept where people
take a set of data,
and then they split in half
and then they search the data,
and then they split
in half again.
I think that's the
tendency that a lot of us
would have in defining
concepts and topics.
But for me, personally, I
think that this definition
works really well in the
context of this video.
Did anyone have any
thoughts about the script
up until this point,
up until right here?
PAUL: This is purely cosmetic.
I thought the
script-- I definitely
understand the basics of binary
search after listening to you,
not even reading the script.
I think that's really good.
Just something I do, and
this is-- you could take it
or you can leave it,
but whenever I do 610--
I don't know, sometimes
if I did hundreds of times
of the Mount Everest, that
kind of-- it could be 100
or can be up to 1,000 so it
scales it a little better,
but that's very
nick-picky I think.
And the other one was over a
1,000 different items, maybe
just thousands of items in
your house or something.
That was it, though.
I thought the rest
was really good.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I thought it
was really beautifully written.
Those layers of complexity,
the way that they--
I'm not someone who processes
particularly well just
by hearing something.
But the way that you brought
me from a simple concept,
to making it more complicated
and more complicated,
and then bringing it
back to the simple.
It was a beautifully
designed piece, really well.
PROFESSOR: But keep in
mind this has happened
over several iterations.
And I wouldn't feel
discouraged if maybe you
feel like your script isn't
in as tight as a place.
Because if you look at
your earlier iterations,
I mean it was a very,
very different idea,
a very different script.
And we talked a lot after class.
Pretty much every day last week.
But I think-- do you feel
happy with how it is right now?
JOSHUA: Yeah, [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: You feel happy.
I think the challenge
is going to be
in realizing this visually.
Because the script itself
is very tightly written,
but executing the whole
hotel analogy, I think,
will be really key.
And it's nice that you
actually have access to a hotel
since you're staying
in the Hyatt right now.
But scaling back far enough
so that people understand, oh,
the key to the reason why
this works is that people are
arranged alphabetically
in ascending,
numerical hotel rooms
is a really vital piece
of information that you can use
the visuals to convey really
well.
Let's see, what about the
second half of the script?
I don't think you need
this last thing right here.
I mean that's what I was
trying to say yesterday.
That oftentimes we
feel like we have
to continue the ending
longer than it needs to be,
like this is why
this is awesome.
And that's the story of search,
and this is the definition
of prime numbers.
It reads a little-- at the end.
I personally just don't
think it's as necessary.
But I like how you tied
it back to your opening.
I think that's very strong.
Does anyone have any
comments about this at all?
FEMALE SPEAKER: On the 80
minutes for the first method
and then 1 1/2 minutes
for binary search,
you explain how
you derive the 80?
Because it's 10 seconds
and there are 500 people.
But then how do you
get the 1 and 1/2?
And I guess my point
is you might not
need the let's say it takes 10
seconds to knock on each door.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's
an interesting point,
because you could explain the
calculations you did to get
to the binary search estimate.
But, again, I don't think it's
super necessary to the point
of the video.
FEMALE SPEAKER: You don't need
the other calculation either
and that'll make it
a little cleaner.
Because I really think the 1
1/2 minutes is very dramatic
in the comparison.
And I started to picture
little pods pop up.
JOSHUA: Because I
was also thinking
about they could be
instead of 500 to 1,000,
it could be 500 to
5,000, but I don't
know how-- I'm not so sure
whether how realistic that
would picture be of
5,000 people in a hotel.
PROFESSOR: But, I mean, I
understand why you brought up
the specific numbers,
because you're
trying to show sense of scale.
That the difference
between the two methods
isn't as exaggerated
when you're only looking
through a few hundred items.
But when you up
that to thousands,
or even close to
what Google searches,
than the difference in the time
becomes super, super dramatic.
In that sense, I
mean, I personally
am totally OK with having
those numbers in there,
because I think that the
script is written naturally
enough to where I'm not
overwhelmed or distracted
too much by the numbers.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I
had one thought.
And I know the
hotel concept works,
because when I
think of a hotel, I
think of a very simple box
with a very linear line
through it and rooms going off
in different directions, which
is why it works.
But I wondered if having
instead of it being a hotel,
it's looking for
something at MIT.
Because then instead of it
being grounded at the hotel,
it grounds the film on campus.
JOSHUA: Yeah, it could
work with-- but I'm not
so familiar of the campus.
Is there a place where--
FEMALE SPEAKER: Totally.
JOSHUA: --it's very uniform--
FEMALE SPEAKER: --very The
infinite corridor, down
the middle hallway, is a very,
very standard place with doors.
That was the only thing
that fundamentally
felt like if we could shift
it, it would help ground this,
instead of being at the Hyatt,
to being here on campus.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's
a nice suggestion.
And there are a couple
fun ways that you could
shoot that if you wanted to--
FEMALE SPEAKER: Getting 5,000
people at MIT is very easy.
PROFESSOR: If you wanted
to shoot centered like this
and start-- whoever is filming
you, start relatively close.
And you have the classrooms
branching off this way.
Does this drawing
make sense to people?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK,
instead-- you'd have
to find some sort of dolly,
maybe take a rolling chair.
But then slowly pan
back as he says,
but if there were
like 5,000 people,
and then it's a nice reveal and
it's an exaggerated angle too.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
knocking on every single door.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, yeah, that'd
be a nice B-roll to put there.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Or even all--
I mean having a little fun.
It's not about [INAUDIBLE]
looking for days
and then all these funny
buildings on campus.
I mean not that it
takes up all our time,
but it's a fun way to
ground this really and being
about an MIT experience.
PROFESSOR: Do you
want to say something?
FEMALE SPEAKER: I think a
really good place for that,
and that's where I
imagined, is Building 4
if you go on the first floor.
That it's just a standard
hallway, and all of the rooms
I'm pretty sure are classrooms
so they're available if you
want to enter them.
And then also there's an
exit to [? Killian ?] Court.
That may be a nice location,
because there's the dome
and grass and all that.
PROFESSOR: Any final
thoughts about this script?
Again, I think it's
come a super long way.
This is pretty much
ready to film, I think.
All right, Kenneth,
you are next.
Do you mind giving
your mic to him?
KENNETH: Do you want to
just do some of this?
Not the whole thing.
Yeah--
FEMALE SPEAKER: It's exactly
talking [INAUDIBLE]--
KENNETH: Yeah, but I don't know.
I just sent-- I just
checked the link
it has the doc-- you know what,
Google Doc has everything.
There's still a few
paragraphs below that.
It's OK, I'll just
read what I have.
FEMALE SPEAKER: When
we read together,
I'll just pull up
the Google Doc.
KENNETH: Yeah, sure.
OK, how do you feel
if you organize
a party and no attends?
Pretty much like
this one right now.
And then it'll show me at the
head of the table with lots
of food and no one.
And I say, oh right, I forgot
to send the invites out.
And then they'll cut to a shot
of me dropping the-- sticks
the envelope into the mailbox.
And I say, hmm, wait a minute.
I guess the only way that anyone
could attend the party right
now is if they actually
travelled back in time.
But if they had
received my invite,
they would have
traveled back in time
and I would have
seen them, and that
means I may not send
out this invitations.
Oh, right.
And then after that
would be-- sorry.
This is actually what
we call a time paradox,
but let me just go in and
talk about-- OK, never mind.
I'm ad-libbing right now.
I'm sorry.
PROFESSOR: That's OK.
In your real thing, you'll
probably be ad-libbing.
KENNETH: Yeah, then somehow
there's a transition.
There will be a transition
so just [INAUDIBLE].
But wait, could we actually
travel through time?
This was in fact an experiment
conducted by Stephen Hawking
in 2009 to show that time travel
was probably improbable to be
invented, even in the future.
But wouldn't being able to
travel through time be cool?
We could submit that homework
that was due yesterday but only
completed today or head
to the really cool party
that I just organized.
But how could we time travel
and is it actually possible?
A lot of what we know
about time travel, all
what we think we know,
comes from Einstein's theory
of special and
general relativity.
Now this is all part of
what we call modern physics
and is still being explored
and tested as we speak.
It doesn't mean that
all of if is wrong.
It just means that we're so
unfamiliar with much of it,
as we are with the
universe around us.
Now back to time traveling.
When you think about it, we are
all actually time traveling,
but not in the manner sci-fi
movies has often depicted them.
We are traveling through time
at a pace of one hour per hour.
In other words, as our bodies
experience an hour of time,
the wall around us has also
experienced an hour of time.
It sounds simple,
but stay with me.
This is where it
gets interesting.
Within Einstein's theory
of special relativity,
there is a phenomenon
he describes,
which is known as time dilation.
And there will be a subtext that
says, dilation means to expend.
Now, the gist of this
phenomenon states
that the faster you travel, the
slower time passes around us.
In other words,
at high speeds, we
could be traveling at a
higher than one hour per hour.
This is, however, only
noticeable traveling at really,
really high speeds, near
the speed of light itself.
And then the c
equals the 3.0 times
10 above 8 meters per
second will appear overhead.
And say I invent a spaceship
that could travel at 90%
the speed of light and I
have a pair of newborn twins.
And I'll have two babies in
my hands, cartoon babies.
And one of them, I'll
put into this spaceship,
and he will be in a spaceship.
And I'll send this spaceship
off to space for a year.
After the baby comes
back for a year,
the baby will have
aged a full one year,
while the one that
remains on the earth
will have aged approximately
2 and 1/2 years old.
We can see that they
have experienced times
at different rates
and the baby on earth
had experienced
times about a 2.3--
has experienced time at a
rate of now 2.3 years per year
where we travel at [? .049 ?] c.
If my spaceship was
capable of traveling
at even higher speeds, now I
fling the baby's to one side.
This rate would
increase exponentially,
as shown in this
particular graph
as you travel toward the speed
of light, which is-- there
will be a graph overlay.
As you travel towards
the speed of light,
the magnitude of the time
would change dramatically
and exponentially.
We could potentially
travel forward in time,
we just have to travel
extremely high speeds to do so.
But, I think the question
on everyone's mind
is, how do we
travel back in time?
I mean surely isn't that a lot
more interesting and a lot--
sorry, I need to scroll back.
Isn't that a lot more
interesting than travelling
forward in time?
Do we have run backwards
really, really quickly?
And then we'll show
the flash running
backwards across the screen.
All this change is
probably just the direction
we're facing as we
travel, unfortunately,
and that doesn't seem
to be helping our case.
Now looking back at
our previous graph,
we can see that the
amount of time that passes
seems to be asymptote
to the speed of light.
What happens on the other
side of the graph then?
Scientists think that the idea
to-- think that the secret
to time traveling
at negative rates,
and subtext negative 3
equals time travel backwards,
lies on the other side.
Rephrasing that, we would
have to travel faster
than the speed of light to maybe
be able to travel back in time.
And this is where the
dicey part comes in.
In general relativity, Einstein
describes another phenomenon
known as relativistic mass.
When you have an
object traveling
at high enough speeds,
the mass of the object
would increase severely.
To move an object with higher
mass at the same velocity,
one would also require
a lot more energy.
Einstein proposes that as we
put more energy into an object,
both the speed and
mass would increase.
However, as we approach
the speed of light,
it is more likely
that the energy
put in increases the
mass of the object,
rather than the
speed of the object.
And thus, to be able
put in enough energy
to push an object beyond
the speed of light, that
will require possibly an
infinite amount of energy,
and thus rendering faster than
light motion highly improbable.
But why are we so
obsessed with time travel?
Time travel often come with
it's own set of problems.
Referring back to
my initial problem,
and say I do have
friends in the future who
are capable of
traveling back in time.
If they received invitations
after the party and travelled
back in time to attend it,
I wouldn't have had an empty
party.
Since I don't have
an empty party,
I wouldn't have to send all
my invitations after it,
and if I had not sent
out my invitations,
they may not have received
it, and they may not
have traveled back in time.
And this is where the whole
confusing part comes in,
and this is what
we call a paradox.
In fact, this
particular paradox is
known as the
grandfather paradox,
in which two conflicting
series of events
occurs, based on whether
I choose to time travel
or not to time travel.
This is just one of the
three theories of time travel
and more details can be
seen at a link below,
and then they'll be a link
to a YouTube description bar.
Because if not, the thing
gets really, really long.
It seems our current
understanding
of modern physics-- based
on our current understanding
of modern physics, time
travel might not be possible
for us to achieve yet.
That's not to say
that things might not
change over the next
decade or the next century
as we are slowly figuring out
the world around us better.
But for now, if they're
going to be planning a party,
be sure to send out the
invitation before it,
and don't count on your
friends on being able to travel
back in time just to attend it.
PROFESSOR: Nice.
All right.
KENNETH: And I know
this one goes way--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, no, it's OK.
This is great
stuff to work with,
and actually I think that
with just a couple fixes,
you will also be pretty
ready to film as well.
This is not your script, you--
KENNETH: Yeah, if you
could open Google doc-- I
just-- I'm not sure.
Because I'm updating it in
Word, it's of-- no, I'm Kenneth.
PROFESSOR: Is it this one?
KENNETH: No, I'm Kenneth.
PROFESSOR: Oh wait,
oh, I'm so sorry.
KENNETH: It's okay.
Yeah, yeah, this should be it.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I
feel like I have
a fairly easy fix for the
time-- speaking of time.
I feel like the whole party
invite thing is too confusing.
KENNETH: Too
confusing, yeah, that's
what I felt when
I was writing it.
But then, the
grandfather paradox is--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I
actually-- I like how
you explain the
paradox at the end
because it answers
the question, well,
if Stephen Hawking proved that
time travel wasn't possible,
then why are we still
thinking about it now?
Like what sort of
loop holes exist?
I think that--
KENNETH: Maybe not
mention [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I know that
you had restructured this.
And I'm guessing
you restructured it,
because George had
said earlier, it
would be nicer if
you could actually
get Stephen Hawking
in this video
as you were talking
about the video
or as you were talking
about the party.
But all this can go away.
I think that you can
explain the set up
with just what you had before.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Why do we need-- I
mean I get that
it's a cool story,
but I feel like you
explaining this idea of-- I
must admit that I have
not yet once in my life
thought about time travel
ever, before this moment.
It's not something
I think about.
In fact, I don't
even think that I
was capable of thinking
about time travel,
because it seems like
this very abstract idea
that my brain probably
doesn't think about
or capable of thinking about.
You did an incredibly good
job at helping me even
understand how
someone would even
think about that
idea, which I think
is the beauty of your piece.
That's like the essence
of what you've done
is you've simplified really
complicated set of theories
and all of that into something
that I could now follow and be
like, oh, I now understand
how people devote their life
into studying this idea.
I would have never, ever
thought about this before.
The party, to me, I don't
need it all in this to me.
Not at the beginning,
not at the end.
The idea is time
travel even possible
is interesting enough
without that story,
from my perspective.
That I think the
party piece is just--
it's got so many
double negatives in it
that it's just
really complicated
to wrap my head around.
I just wonder what it would look
like if we took the party thing
out entirely and focused on--
KENNETH: I was actually
thinking an alternate was maybe
a B-roll of footage
from Hollywood films
of people traveling back in
time like in Harry Potter
or in Star Trek.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I don't
think you need it, I mean,
personally.
PROFESSOR: Then there's like
a whole IP issue, which we're
going to talk about it an hour.
I mean here's the
thing-- and again, this
is the part where like
personal taste comes into play.
I think that the story is nice
as a storytelling element.
That you end the video
nicely, because you reference
the beginning, where
you're just like just
send out your annotations.
But I do agree that it takes a
really long time to explain it,
and I wonder if you can cut
this intro down to a sentence.
I think this is an OK
start, held a party,
but you can take
out all this stuff.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I guess I
get lost with the he sent
the invitations, no one came.
How does that-- I don't know.
It's really-- maybe I'm
less adept at thinking
this way than the
rest of this room,
but I really struggle with this.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, PJ?
PAUL: One thing I found
when I was redoing my script
was-- mine was pretty
wordy to begin with
and I think the story--
I think it's good,
and I think you get
a lot of those words
based off what we were shooting.
There's no one
there, and the fact
that you're describing
again, I don't
think you have to do it because
they're going to get all that.
I like the Stephen
Hawking story,
but like it was with [INAUDIBLE]
doing a sentence based
on all the visual queues they're
going to get from the video.
PROFESSOR: Because I like that
you talk about the grandfather
paradox.
And I actually didn't super
understand the grandfather
paradox until I heard you
read this paragraph aloud
in the context of the party.
But again, Paul
is totally right.
You can complete
rely on the visuals
to tell a lot of
these words for you.
So you could say, back in 2009,
Stephen Hawking held a party
that no one came to you,
and he smiled at himself,
because he had just proven
that time travel was possible.
All right, so you're
reducing everything
down into a sentence.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Not possible.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
is not possible.
The reason is that he
sent his invitations out
after the party had
finished, thinking
that if people in the future
were capable of time travel,
they'd receive those
invitations after the party had
ended and come.
So, because the party was empty,
time travel is not possible.
You know I mean?
Really, really condense
it down to two sentences.
Really challenge
yourself to explain
the story in two sentences.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And
I might need a-- I
mean, for me, I might actually
want an animation in this part
too.
I don't know.
I don't know why I find
it really complicated.
PROFESSOR: It is, it's a
complicated-- it's complicated
because you don't really explain
it until the very end, which
is OK.
I agree that it's not
vital to your content,
that the content is
fascinating enough.
But it's used really well,
right now, as the storytelling
device to open and close the
video, and then in the middle,
you bring it up again.
I think that there's a
lot of stuff in the video
that you can take out
that might give you
some time to play around with.
For example, this whole
chunk can be cut down a lot.
Let me change this to--
I'll just resolve this.
I think the question that
you can set yourself up with
is, so time travel-- if
you disprove time travel,
why are we still fascinated
by-- or why do physicists still
think about it?
Well, what exactly
is time travel?
A lot of this--
KENNETH: In otherwords--
PROFESSOR: Here, I don't
I think you necessarily
need these two sentences.
I also wonder if you
need this paragraph here.
Yeah, I mean it's fun.
It's going to be a little
hard to execute visually given
the amount of time
you have left.
So, just from a production
standpoint, it'll be tricky.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Actually,
this really worked for me.
PROFESSOR: It did?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah,
at least for me.
When you-- I mean
with the babies,
you don't actually
need real babies.
You can have dolls, right?
KENNETH: No, I was thinking
of just cartoon babies.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah,
or whatever-- plus,
as a mother-- oh, there's no way
I would lend you my [INAUDIBLE]
for this film.
No offense, but there
is no way I would
lend a child for this film.
But I think that this example
actually was very concrete
and I think [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes.
PAUL: I'm just going to say
that example, I thought,
was really good too.
But I think you can--
not the sentence
before but the paragraph before,
you could turn that into one
thought, because
you're explaining how
you travel in hour per hour.
I think if you were
able to just maybe get
a sentence out of that and
just get rid of the rest
and then blend it with that now
I take a pair of newborn twins'
paragraph, that'd be good.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I
think the only issue
with it is that it takes so long
to getting to explain to how we
travel backwards in
time, and I don't
know from the beginning
of the script,
that you're planning
on explaining that.
And then I'm just
sort of waiting
to see where you'll go next.
Maybe if you preface I'm going
to explain what time traveling
is.
You can say, well,
first-- in your own words,
you can say first
I'm going to talk
about how we travel forward in
time, and then backward in time
or somehow indicate
that to the viewer.
I don't know if anyone
else felt that confusion.
Sorry, Andrea.
ANDREA: I almost wonder
if you shouldn't you
lead off with the baby example.
As like let's do
this experiment,
let's do this side
experiment where we do this.
And it might-- I think
it'll help with your pacing.
It was difficult
for me to listen to.
It was pretty wordy.
I think if you
actually like just
grabbed two props as
though you're acting it out
and ad-lib it and record
yourself doing it,
you'll get something that flows
a lot better, because you'll be
able to cut out a lot of words.
Because you'd be like,
here's a one-year-old baby
and here's a 2 and
1/2 year-old toddler.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
ANDREA: That's
what would happen.
PROFESSOR: There are a lot of
just little phrases like this
like we are with the universe
around us that are very poetic.
They sound really
nice in an essay.
But if you actually
strip some of this
away and really just
try to distill it down
to the essential facts,
I think that's going
to save you a lot of time too.
But, overall, at this
point it seems more
like distilling ideas sound.
Do people agree with that?
I'm glad that you
flushed it out, though,
because before it was
sort of missing some
of the essential
explanations, and I
know you were worried about it
getting too long because of it.
But I think the overall
structure of it is very sound.
Yes, Julia?
JULIA: Well, I was going to say
that all of the topics involved
in the script kind of to
me don't seem necessarily
connected, because
the paradoxes are more
in the field of philosophy,
and then relativity is physics,
and then the twin paradox
is a thought experiment
so that's closer to philosophy.
I think it will be nice to
separate the two to mention
this is actually
scientifically proven
and this is just something
that people think about.
Also, the most compelling
part to me was,
and that's something that
answers the question of time
travel the best, is the part
where he talks about traveling
forward in time and
travelling backwards in time.
And the backward part was not
very flushed out whereas there
was a lot of time spent
on the twin paradox that
doesn't necessarily have to
do that much with time travel.
Do you think there's a
way to restructure it?
Or focus on something other
than time travel that would be
paradoxes that arise when
you work with relativity
and travelling at
the speed of light?
That would be the twin paradox
and the grandfather paradox,
and then you could explain
them in more detail.
Especially for the
grandfather paradox
that would help, because you
could split up the explanation
into different sentences so
you wouldn't use would of
and had multiple times.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I
mean the only thing
is that you are working with
a very tight time constraint.
And I think all of this
information is nice
and it's good and, it helps
me understand it better.
And would work
really well if this
were a blog post, for instance.
But you do only have
four or five minutes.
And I actually
like the structure
that you have waiting until
the end to address the paradox,
because you're kind of
going back to the beginning.
And you're saying, why
isn't time travel possible,
aside from the
fact that we can't
go beyond the speed of light.
How else are you going to
support Stephen Hawking's claim
that time travel isn't possible?
I like that the
way you've split up
putting the paradox at the end.
I don't know how you
guys feel about it.
How do you guys feel about
the overall structure
of the script?
MALE SPEAKER: I think
that he has to-- I think
a paradox should be at the end.
I think time travelling
backwards should be after time
travelling forward.
I think that he--
correct me if I'm wrong,
but I think that you don't have
enough information for time
travelling backwards because
nobody knows how to do it.
Nobody knows the [INAUDIBLE]
travel backwards in time,
so you can't give a really
concrete example for it.
PROFESSOR: Right, like you
can't have an analogous example.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, because
we don't really know.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Nathan, did--
MALE SPEAKER: I
think [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, Nathan did
you want to say something?
NATHAN: Oh, I just thought that
Chris saying the structure-- I
actually really liked how
everything was laid out.
And that I feel like
most of the work
is just shortening
individual parts.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I agree
with Nathan on that.
And honestly, the thing
about the traveling backwards
in time, for me
personally, it's just
that you don't get
to it soon enough, so
that I feel like we're
wading through a lot of intro
and a lot of explanation
of moving forward,
which are important.
I wouldn't say take them
out completely or anything.
But that I had no
idea what any of this
was actually before I read this.
And I'm glad that you put it
in there, because that's really
what the meat of it is.
What exactly does it mean
to travel back in time?
And at first I was like,
why is he putting graphs up?
This is being really
physicsy, but now I
understand why you're
talking about asymptotes
and everything.
It's just that it took a
really long time to get there.
And--
FEMALE SPEAKER: I think,
if I hear everyone, we just
be ruthless going
through paragraphs
and cut it-- information that
you don't think is essential.
Because the overall
structure works, but there's
just too much.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I think
this paragraph is very vital
and I would shorten
that unless you're
like going to take
out fluffy words.
If anything, I would take out
from this stuff before it.
And this stuff is
super interesting,
and I don't want
you to take it out
because it's a further
explanation of why
time travel isn't possible.
But it gets really dense here.
This is the part when
you were talking where
I was like what is happening.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
That's another video.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, this is OK.
But this paragraph, can you just
say that would-- it would also
need a lot more energy, actually
an infinite amount of energy
to move it.
Traveling faster than the speed
of light is highly improbable.
KENNETH: I'm just afraid that
it condenses the whole chunk
on traveling back in time--
PROFESSOR: --too much.
KENNETH: Yeah, that's why I
decided to talk a little more.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
No, and I'm glad that
you flush it out.
I know that you were
hesitant to add more stuff,
because you were aware
of the time constraint.
MALE SPEAKER: And mention
e equals mc squared.
KENNETH: Not exactly.
It's, effectively, he goes--
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE] e
equals mc squared then as he
increase e-- as e increases--
normally you'd think that m
stays the same and c increases--
KENNETH: Actually, e equals
the [INAUDIBLE] mc squared.
That's why I didn't really
want to bring it in.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Yeah, I don't think you should
add any equations to this.
Aside from the fact that
like e equals mc squared
is like the characteristic
Einstein equation that people--
KENNETH: But the thing
is, it doesn't really
fully explain this.
That's why I didn't
really feel like putting
the other equation in.
PROFESSOR: I agree
with Jamie, overall.
The structure, I
think, is there.
The substance is there.
I don't think you
necessarily need
to add anything except for
maybe a transitioner or so.
But at this point, I really
think it's just, again,
being ruthless about
taking words out, taking
a sentence out or two.
You're only over
by a few minutes,
which actually is an eternity.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
[INAUDIBLE] fast.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And I will say
that slowing down your pace
will help people--
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
I think I started
getting lost around
the Einstein,
because you were talking a lot
faster in that section too.
But I'd say at this point it's
really just paring it down
to the essentials.
And we can help you with
that during office hours
if you want.
Any final thoughts for Kenneth?
Yeah, Joshua?
JOSHUA: I do agree
with your point
just now about [INAUDIBLE].
I think it's helpful.
It's been a bit confusing
the [INAUDIBLE].
KENNETH: Yeah, I was thinking
whether I should even
mention a paradox straight
off or not to mention it
at the top.
That's why I was
just playing around.
And, yeah, I think no.
JOSHUA: Is there a to
phrase it in the positive?
FEMALE SPEAKER: You're saying
because the double negatives
are really confusing?
JOSHUA: Yes.
I was thinking perhaps
it might be something
like he was happy because he
proved time travelers wrong,
and they could not
come back in time.
So he makes it very clear
that once that-- perhaps it's
like once [INAUDIBLE]
proved time travel wrong.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, maybe just a
little wording thing like that.
JOSHUA: He might lose
a level of complexity
that you would want
people-- I guess
it's not the intent to help
them understand this part.
The intent is to tell them
that Stephen Hawking proved
time travel is wrong?
Is that [INAUDIBLE]?
Then you might be OK to
hide the complexity away.
[INAUDIBLE]
Just keep thinking about
why is that, why is that--
how did that prove it?
How did that prove [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: And you talk
about it at the end.
I think the whole grandfather
paradox part is nice,
because it is an expansion
of why maybe his proof wasn't
really a proof and
why people are still
thinking about time travel
even though he supposedly
proved that it wasn't possible.
FEMALE SPEAKER: What if you
take the structured approach
that Josh took in his whole
piece in that little part?
Make it really simple at first.
Stephen Hawking hosted a party.
No one showed up.
It proved that time
travel wasn't possible.
Actually, it's a little
more complicated,
and explain it a little further.
PROFESSOR: Actually, you could
open the video like that.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
FEMALE SPEAKER: Just
really tight and then it
allows you to use that story
throughout, but not confusing
people with all the details.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Right?
PROFESSOR: PJ were you
going to say something?
OK.
All right, any final thoughts?
I mean this is in
good shape too.
Again, it's much
easier to-- I think
it's easier to pair
down from something
that has too much content then
the other way around for sure.
And the delivery
again will help too.
FEMALE SPEAKER: These
have come so far.
PROFESSOR: They really have.
I mean I don't know if you guys
have looked at your pitches
that you made last week.
But they really have--
I mean I'm really
excited to watch these videos.
Yes.
JULIA: I'm just going
to say that I really
liked how you were
able to explain
this complex phenomenon in
words that are understandable.
KENNETH: [INAUDIBLE].
JULIA: Yeah, I think
that's really cool.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, and that's
the whole building learning
confidence with the
viewer too that I talked
about on the first day of--
simple explainer videos
are so compelling to
people even though they're
quote unquote boring,
because people feel good
when they feel like
they've mastered
a seemingly complex subject.
And this is a video that is
going to help people understand
special relativity.
I think that it's going to
be a very compelling thing
to watch for people.
They're going to
want to keep watching
because they're understanding
what you're saying.
All right.
FEMALE SPEAKER: You
seem so smart when
you get something complicated.
I'm like, oh wow, I just got a
really complicated [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
you're helping them
achieve mastery, which is nice.